as a young boy i would fantasize what it
would be like to be in a band is it all
it's cracked up to be it's a big
question um
i don't think there's anything i can't
imagine doing anything better or more
fun or more exciting um
you know we've traveled
so many places you know we've we've
probably traveled to
to more places you know than we would
have traveled in
50 lifetimes but
you know there's amazing highs and of
course there's lows and of course
there's definitely spinal tap moments
you know that people don't get
what are the lows are the lows the the
traveling and being away from your
family and the road so to speak uh that
has been challenging in the past i think
we've got a better system now for for
working through that
but of course you know life is very
different for us now because we've got
you know there's lots of
children um
that we have to you know incorporate
into all of these
in
plans
words uh now when you guys tour you
bring the kids with you and you try to
keep the family together
we try to where possible and that that
that's given a kind of a completely
fresh perspective on on going out
touring actually it's kind of it's
opened up in a different way because
you're seeing
a lot of places
that you've been to before through
someone else's eyes how many kids are on
the tour now i mean what's what's going
on there it sounds like uh 10 or with
phil 13.
jesus
yeah it's like i actually got yeah each
preschool yeah it's great
is it dangerous to take your kids on
tour because they start to look at you
in a different way in other words uh
you're taking the spotlight away from
them i think it's quite the opposite
they've got the most amazing ability to
slice us in half and level us down to
the ground our kids have a wide range in
age but
certainly the teenagers have a kind of
ability to
to to just
completely
ignore or disregard whatever it is that
parents do and so actually
taking them and reminding them that
their their dads are actually
well used to be cool or at some point
some people think they're cool it's
actually really it's really lovely and
um my kids are like ah
i get it now
you